- Good morning, good afternoon,
hello, hi, it's Justine.
And this is my channel.
If you guys are new here, welcome.
I have had quite an influx
of subscribers lately,
and it's been super fun.
So to anyone who has joined
my channel from that,
welcome, I am excited that you're here.
I make videos on YouTube,
and I've been doing it
for about 11 years, and sometimes
when I think about that,
it is insane.
It's actually really crazy.
I have a dog.
His name's Matty.
I have an addiction to Amiibo.
I like video games, I
like food, I like candy.
I like eating pizza a lot.
I'm not a very good cook.
But yet I do try.
I really like succulents.
I like Star Wars, although I
never saw Star Wars as a kid.
So I like Star Wars as an adult,
having seen the Star Wars movies
and watching them in the
completely wrong order.
Anyway, my point in this
video is I am also a vlogger.
And sometimes when I think about vlogging
and how long I've been vlogging
and how much incredible
content that I have to go back
and to watch is really, really fun.
But recently, I've been
having this feeling
of I don't want to vlog.
It's this weird feeling
where I don't want to film something.
I don't want to have a camera in my face.
I don't want to have a
camera in my friends' faces,
which is why my vlogs have been sort
of non-existent, really.
But today, I'm gonna be
posting a really long vlog,
because these are all
of the vlogs that I've,
how many times am I gonna say vlog?
I've been filming videos,
but I just haven't been posting them.
So I thought all of those videos and vlogs
that I have filmed, that are
probably so old, at this point,
I'm just gonna post it all in one video.
And that's this video.
But today, we're gonna start
out with what I do today.
(laughs) Some of these clips
that you guys are gonna see,
it's from like a month ago.
And I was asking myself,
am I a bad vlogger?
I think you get burned out
making videos, every single day,
about your life, about
the most mundane things.
And I have so many props to people
who can do this, every single
day, because I just can't,
because at some point,
I actually was living my
life in post-production.
I still edit almost all of my own videos.
So I will go and do something
super fun and super cool,
and then I'm not really
enjoying it, in the moment.
I enjoy that moment later,
when I'm actually editing,
and I'm making whatever it was
that I did into a fun story,
a fun story that I get to tell you guys,
a fun story of how I want to remember
whatever it was that I was doing.
And I'm so grateful that that is something
that I get to do, but
after doing it for so long,
it does start to sort of affect
how you do things, I guess,
on a daily basis, because you wake up,
and you say, I don't
have a video for today.
What can I go do that will be
cool to make a video about?
And you don't wake up
and say, wow, I'm gonna
go have a great day
and enjoy it and spend it and live it.
I'm gonna film it and record it.
I'm not complaining.
I'm just saying it's a different
way that, who I think a lot
of people who make
videos, every single day,
kind of take on their day,
if that makes any sense.
So I guess what I've been trying
to do is have more pre-edited
content and having things
where I don't feel so stressed out
that if I wake up, and
I don't have a video,
it's gonna be okay.
I try to post videos,
every day, but lately,
it hasn't been every day.
I'd rather post better videos for you
than have something that's
sort of forced content.
If I don't have something good,
I mean, and to be honest with
you, a lot of that reason is
because I can't vlog
myself sitting right here,
playing Zelda, all day, unless
I'm a streamer, and I'm not.
I will tell you, my house is such a mess.
It needs cleaned.
Here's a picture of Matty,
that my sister got me, for my birthday.
You'll see that pretty
soon, when I unbox that,
'cause clearly, I haven't
posted that video yet, either.
Right now, the dog is going
to go to the groomers,
which I'm pretty sure I have a clip
of me doing that, several weeks ago.
Hello, my little pig.
Hi, honey.
Anyway, I gotta go, because
he's got to get his hair cut.
I've got my bag all packed.
Shout out to my friend Amy.
I met her on the Internet,
and this is her book.
It's called Vlog Like a Boss.
She is so awesome.
I'm gonna put a link in the description
if you guys want to get this.
There's also a little quote from me
and also some other
YouTubers too, on the back,
so be sure to check that out.
She's awesome and just a
super incredible, kind girl,
and she makes really fun videos.
So go check her out.
I gotta go, I gotta go.
See, this is the thing with the vlogging,
is nothing is ever just, okay, let's go.
It's okay, let's go.
Now we gotta film it,
and then I gotta get a different angle,
and then, is the lighting okay?
I wonder how long this vlog is gonna be.
Oh my goodness.
- Wanna go get mama?
- Come here, you.
- Get her!
- You handsome, little man.
Look at you, ooh.
Look at you, look at you.
- [Woman] Oh what's up here?
Is there something there for me?
(Justine laughs)
- So we're back here,
getting my hair done, today.
I think we're gonna try to
do it a little bit darker
but not like too dark.
So we'll see what happens.
But here we go.
(gentle music)
I did something really stupid today.
I was editing, and I basically
deleted half of the video
that I was editing, and
it's a super long video.
It's probably about almost 25, 30 minutes.
It was the video that I posted yesterday,
with the Zelda gameplay in it.
And sometimes, if there's a bottom clip
that's attached to a top clip,
that you're trying to delete,
the clip that's attached to
the clip that you're trying
to delete sometimes will
just select everything,
and then it deletes all of it.
And I didn't realize it
until I was done editing the entire video.
So I had to export the
end part of the video,
go back and find an old
saved library from yesterday,
where I had edited the first half.
And then once I had that, I
then took the end-bottom piece
and then pieced it back
together, for the beginning part,
but then had to fill in the
blanks in the beginning,
and oh my goodness,
it's just, it's (sighs),
but thankfully, it all worked out.
And it only cost me maybe an
extra hour or so of editing,
but I definitely did not account for that.
So here's the new hair,
which I didn't show you guys.
Can you tell that it's different?
This is much darker, and
this is a little lighter,
so now it all kind of matches.
There was just a lot of stuff going on.
I'm getting gas right now.
I got a Starbucks.
I've got a cold.
I've got a hot.
I've been having a problem lately,
because I've been drinking both of them.
I can never usually decide if
I want a hot or a cold drink,
so I end up instead of
getting a venti of one,
I just get a tall of two,
and it works out great.
It's been a really, really great system.
And I just got my birthday
reward, today, so hallelujah!
I didn't use it, though,
because I'm using that
on a venti, for sure.
My car was basically completely empty.
20 gallons, it's still goin'.
I don't even know how I got here.
Oh my, oh, it's still goin'.
Okay, maybe I have a
bigger tank than I thought.
(door beeps)
All right, let's go.
(door thuds)
I am off to shoot,
today, a fun little video
with Sara Dietschy.
She is an awesome YouTuber,
and she's in L.A., right now,
and was like, hey, you
want to shoot a video?
And I said yeah, I do!
Yeah, I set my GoPro up
for some driving shots,
because why not?
(camera beeps)
I apologize in advance for
15 different frame rates
in this video.
(gentle music)
All right, guys, this is a sight to see.
You know, it's not bad enough
that I'm carrying one coffee.
I'm carrying two, and they're both for me.
This is ridiculous.
So guys, I finally made it.
I was just telling Sara, too,
about the struggle (laughs)
of deleting my entire video.
- It's something that always happen.
No matter how long you make videos,
you just make those mistakes.
- Well, yeah, and I feel
like we're always in a hurry,
'cause we put out a lot of content.
You post a lot, too.
- It's fun.
Monday through Friday,
it keeps me on my toes.
It's never perfect, though.
You always have to deal with the guilt
of not posting a video,
missing it.
- I know.
- And it tears you apart,
but it's like the world does go on.
- Yeah, I mean, I post every day.
(Sara laughs)
You guys know
what that means.
It's like I say that, but every day,
there's gonna be something, somewhere.
- You are so good with variety.
- Well, thank you.
- You crush it.
It's like your a tech
ninja but also cooking
(Justine chuckles)
and just lifestyle,
and it's amazing.
- That's great.
Well, this vlog is like a month long.
So the rest of this video is
basically what I've been doing
for the past month, so it's great.
But we just filmed some really fun videos
that will be out like next week-ish.
You guys will know.
But this is Sara.
Wait, here's the better lighting,
this way.
- Oh yes,
yes, yes.
- So this is Sara.
- Hi, guys!
- Go check out her channel
and prepare yourself
for our Apple Watch video.
- It's fun, yeah.
Yes, Apple Watch, we
both rock the ceramic.
And I just want to say thank you
for including me in this.
- No--
- You're amazing.
- Oh, well, thank you.
- I know your peeps know this,
but you, she is amazing.
- Oh thank you.
- I would watch you, like
four or five years ago.
- [Justine] Oh my goodness.
- This kid in high school thinking,
maybe I could make
Internet videos, one day.
- And here you are.
- And here, so it's huge.
- You're crushing it.
- It's a big deal, 'cause you're
a huge inspiration to me.
- Why thank you.
- You are.
- And she likes drones,
and I have not got into
Boosted board, but when I do,
I'm calling you (laughs).
- Yes, hands down.
We'll Boost around New York City.
- (gasps) I can't do that.
- [Sara] I believe in you, Justine.
- I don't think so.
- You can do it.
I believe in you.
- Well, thank you so much
for having me in your video.
- Yes, thank you.
- Thank you.
(Sara laughing)
Guess I'll figure out
which coffee I'm gonna drink next.
- This is so amazing.
This right here, please,
did you explain to them
what you did.
- Yeah, I couldn't decide.
So here we are.
- [Sara] Mad props.
- Today, we're at the YouTube Space,
and we're doing something super cool.
Right now, we're gonna be hopping into VR.
There's gonna be people
joining us VR, but the people
that are joining us are
not just any people.
They are
the Power Rangers.
So here's what it actually
looks like, right up here.
(playful music)
So all those people
actually have headsets on,
so they are in our virtual
reality environment.
It's kind of hard to explain,
but I will show you guys
a quick clip, right here,
of what we're actually doing.
- Woo!
- Hey!
- [Justine] Hey, everyone.
I am Justine Ezarik.
- Hi!
- And I am so excited to welcome everyone
to the Power Rangers
Virtual Reality Experience.
So we are joined here by the stars
of the new Power Rangers
film, so say hello, everybody.
- Hey!
- Hi!
- What's up, guys?
- Oh my gosh,
the Power Rangers!
- We have our Red Ranger,
Dacre Montgomery.
- Hello!
- We've got our Black Ranger, Ludi Lin.
- [Ludi] What's up, dudes
and dudettes?
- Pink Ranger, Naomi Scott.
- Hi!
- Hey!
- Our Blue Ranger, over here, RJ Cyler.
- Holla!
- And our Yellow Ranger, Becky G.
- Hey!
- Yo!
- Okay, I got to hop in the VR now.
We're doing the live VR panel.
So I'm interviewing the Power Rangers,
as myself but an avatar of myself.
So it's like I'm a body of pixels.
(upbeat music)
Well, we just finished
doing the VR experience.
It was nuts, because towards the end,
everybody started going crazy with avatars
that I was actually getting
stepped on in VR life.
It was so crazy.
(romantic music)
Oh (laughs)!
- Hey, come on, they're here.
- Oh my goodness.
- Oh my!
- Do you want me to
take her off the leash?
- [Woman] Yes.
- Sure.
- Anybody.
- Oh my god.
- I feel like
he's not gonna take it.
- Matty, it's your girlfriend.
- So this vlog just
turned from Power Rangers
to now we're watching The
Bachelor or Bachelorette.
I have no idea.
I've never watched the show,
but apparently, this is the finale.
- Someone's either gonna
get married or get booted.
That's what I hear.
- But is this the finale?
- I think so.
- This is the finale.
- Oh!
- Final rose and everything.
- So I'm assuming that these
are the last girls that are,
these two, they look exactly the same.
When I walked in earlier,
I came over here,
and I was like oh, look
at this cute picture
of Ro and Molly, and I was
like, that's not Ro and Molly.
Who are these strangers in their house?
Guys, look who's here.
Francesca.
- Long lost.
- I haven't seen you, it's been so long.
- I know.
- When have I seen you last?
- The Superbowl.
- Oh wow.
Yeah, that's a while ago.
- Then you went gallivanting
off to the Islands.
(Justine laughs)
You got really sick.
- Yeah.
- I want to go
on a hike, this week, with the girls.
- That'd be nice.
Yeah, I need to get outside.
I've just been playing
Nintendo, and it's bad news.
- I heard it's really good.
- Oh my god.
- It's like an 11 out of 10 points.
- (gasps) So fun.
- Ew, Ava.
- And here's Ava.
- Ava, come say hi.
- Hi, sweetie.
You look beautiful.
- [Francesca] She's like, I'm beautiful.
I'm pretty.
I'm crazy.
- Yes, you are.
- You like cucumber.
- Oh my.
And there's Jenna, hi.
- Hi.
- Did I already say hi to you, in my vlog?
- No, but I was peakin'
in the back of one.
I was like...
- So I haven't watched...
So wait, is it The Bachelor
or The Bachelorette
that we're watching?
- Bachelor.
- Okay, so that's the
guy is picking the girls.
- [Francesca] Yeah, and he's boring.
- [Justine] Yeah?
- He's boring.
- I haven't seen anything,
never seen one single episode of any.
- [Francesca] I don't think
he's gonna pick anybody.
- I haven't either.
They once came up to me and asked
if I was interested in being
on the show.
- You should do it.
- And then when I told her--
- Then they said
she's too old.
- No, no, no.
She goes, "Well, how old are you?"
And I told her, and she's like (gasps),
"Well, you can still come in.
"You can come in for the meeting, anyway."
- Maybe like, maybe you can be like--
- If you don't have
cellulite, and you're tan,
then you're eligible.
- I was like, uh, I'm good, thank you.
- That is cold.
- Maybe you could go
for like the Grandma Bachelor.
(Justine laughs)
- Don't worry, I'll be there
as the great-grandmother.
- [Jenna] I meant by LA standards.
- You know what?
- Hollywood standards.
(Justine grunts)
We're young and vibrant.
- I'm okay.
- Look at me, I'm out past 7:30 (laughs).
- You're crazy.
- That's true.
Okay, where's my dog.
- [Raven] I promise you
that I would not be here--
(guests chattering)
- Guys, look at all the dogs.
This is incredible.
Henry and Cookie, and this is Lou.
Ava's over there.
Where's our baby at?
- I don't know.
Cheating on us.
- Where's Matty?
So we're watching the show now.
(guests chattering)
I can't believe this is a real show,
and people watch this.
This is unbelievable.
- This is trash.
(guests chattering)
- What do you think of the show, Ro?
What do you think?
- Well, I think I called it.
I had a good feeling.
We have been playing the fantasy league
of Bachelor.
- Oh my god!
- In my defense, I thought
Corinne was gonna win,
so I was a little off, but
Vanessa was a close second.
And I think that's gonna happen.
- Ooh, oh, look at the hug.
It's just--
- My favorite part of this, Justine,
is he goes, "I'm gonna miss you."
And she goes, "I know."
- [Jenna] She said that?
- That's good.
Ro is passing out gifts.
So you had to guess who
you thought was gonna win.
Did you get, you won!
- Oh I got it.
I am The Love Doctor, they call me.
- [Justine] Oh I see.
- These are even, these are branded,
branded candies or something.
- Oh my goodness.
- Oh it's from Sugarfina.
- Ooh!
- It's real good.
This is like primo candy.
- That is good.
- It's, oh, roses!
- Wow.
- Go figure, go figure.
I also guessed correctly.
But I also cheated.
So I said that I cheated.
So I'm not sure if I'm gonna
actually get the candy or not.
- Did you write on the thing?
- I did.
- You did?
- Yeah, I did.
- At least you're honest about it.
- But I also guessed this girl,
just judging by purely off of like--
- It was, for me, shallow,
completely shallow,
just based off looks.
- Wow, wow, this show,
I don't even want to talk about it.
I'm done.
We're done here.
I hope I get the candy, though.
- I cheated, Justine.
We'll still give you--
- [Justine] Thank you, thank you.
- A winning gift.
That's okay.
You were honest.
- I don't deserve this.
I don't deserve it.
(playful music)
Hello, it's been a really long time
since I've vlogged.
If you guys are following
me on Twitter, Instagram
or anywhere else, then you
know I've been incredibly sick
for the past week.
Most of you seem to think
it's because of my cooking.
And I really probably
wouldn't disagree with you.
So for the past week,
I've been pretty much sitting
right here on this couch,
playing Zelda and being
extremely, deathly ill.
And when I wasn't playing
Zelda, I was in bed sleeping
or taking the dog for a walk.
What else are we wondering, Justine?
Why are there six laundry baskets here?
Well, there's only supposed
to be one laundry basket,
but for some reason, I guess
I didn't read the description
on Amazon, and it was
actually six laundry baskets.
So now I have an abundance
of laundry baskets.
I'm gonna pack up my Switch,
and I'm gonna go visit Jenna,
because Matty is gonna go to the DP.
That's short for dog park.
I can't say it out loud,
because he gets too excited.
For those of you
who sent me get-well-soon
wishes, thank you.
I'm finally starting to feel better.
It was pretty much the worst week ever.
The Nintendo Switch doesn't
have any carrying cases out yet.
That's not true, they're out.
I just can't get them.
They're all sold out.
So I'm using this little toiletry bag.
So we're just gonna put this in, like so,
controls, and that's really all I need.
Time to go visit Jenna.
Oh I forgot.
I need my Amiibo trading cards
so that I could import some goodies.
Nintendo Switch in.
We are on our way to see my sister.
I can't say her name,
because the dog knows it.
(laughs) Matty, are you excited?
(playful music)
Oh my god.
- Oh my (laughs).
- You guys are crazy.
Matty's been cooped up for the past week,
and he is beyond excited to
be at the dog park, right now.
He made a new little girlfriend.
Look at this picture.
It is so cute.
They're holding paws.
(gasps) My heart.
Is anybody thirsty?
Do you guys want to get a drink?
Ooh, what's here?
Some presents for Jenna.
Did you have fun at the dog park, Matty?
You made a girlfriend.
Hey, can I borrow your microphone, please.
- [Jenna] Yeah, I was
just about to use it.
- Oh.
So mine took quite the tumble.
This whole plastic part broke,
which the microphone is probably fine,
but I need to get another mount.
So that happened.
Jenn, we gonna unbox it now?
- [Jenna] Yeah, we are, girl.
- We're about to unbox
Jenna's Nintendo Switch
This is big news.
- [Jenna] Big news.
- Very big news.
I also brought you another
present that I'll let you unbox.
- [Jenna] Wow.
Do you already know what it is?
- Yes.
- (laughs) Cool.
- Yeah.
What did you get me?
What's in here?
What's (gasps), Matty!
(Jenna laughs)
It's you, baby, look!
- It's the--
- Oh my goodness!
- Is that you?
Is that the dog?
- Guys, look, it's Matty!
- It's the Pop Your Pup thing,
so it's like the pop art.
- (gasps) It's so cute.
Thank you.
- Look at him, that's our baby.
- Oh my goodness.
(gasps) Matty, where we gonna put this?
This is so cute.
- [Jenna] They have all kinds
of different backgrounds,
but the blue looked good.
They have like pizza and like poop.
- Oh, it looks so good.
I love you, Matty.
Oh tell Jenna, thank you.
Jenn, there's you Switch.
It's been unboxed.
- [Jenna] Yay!
- [Justine] What do you think?
- I'm excited.
I have to charge it and set it up
and figure out how to play
Zelda and read this whole book.
I've got a lot of work to do.
- So I've never been
one to buy game guides
for anything, and for Zelda, I did,
because there are so many
little, small, tiny things
that when I got the game,
there was absolutely nothing
online, when I got the game,
so this was kind of like
my only source of hey,
I'm stuck at a shrine.
I'm desperate.
I don't know what to do.
For the most part, I've been
able to figure out everything.
But it is so nice to be able
to have something to reference,
because let me tell you what.
This game's hard.
- Oh my gosh.
Well, now I'm just gonna reference you,
'cause I don't, I already,
you already--
- Well, I had nobody
to talk to.
I was talking to like Maven,
and we're just chatting and--
- (chuckles) He loves Zelda.
- It's so fun.
(Switch clicks)
Wow, wow.
Well, I guess now that you're doing that,
I can go play my game.
- Is it like a step-by-step?
- There is, but don't do the walkthrough.
I mean, I only reference
it when I'm like okay,
I am confused, and I need help.
But now there's actually stuff online,
so you can find information,
whereas before, there was nothing,
and I was stuck.
- That's good.
- Uh, yeah.
Office still the kitchen.
And if you're wondering why,
the roof of my office was leaking.
So I had people come in to fix said leak,
but now, I'm resorted with working here.
So I figure the rest of
this vlog is gonna be
from some clips from
the past couple of weeks
that I never even posted.
I mean, I went to Disney,
didn't even post the vlog.
I was hanging out with Ro,
and I had just got back
from vacation, so put
yourself in the mindset
of a few weeks ago.
Today is Matty's day.
We're off to get a little haircut,
'cause he definitely needs a trim.
It's been raining so much in Los Angeles
for the past week and a half or so,
that this dog has gotten disgusting.
Just like my house.
My sister Jenna, as you guys,
you've seen her in my videos,
yes, actual sister, not
like fraternity sister
or just calling her my sister for the sake
of calling her my sister,
actual real-life sister,
Jenna was watching Matty.
She was watching him
while I was on vacation.
I actually went on a real vacation.
I didn't edit for almost
six days straight.
I haven't done that probably
in 11 years, which is insane.
I didn't film anything.
That's not true.
I actually made it maybe
two days without vlogging,
and I missed it, so I
did vlog a little bit.
But it wasn't like I had to do it,
because I had prepped ahead of
time almost a week of videos
so that I could actually
take a legit time off
from the Internet, and it was incredible.
It was great, a real vacation.
Who would've thought that's a thing?
This ChapStick is Cake Batter.
So now that I'm back, I've got my laptop,
so I'm gonna edit while
Matty gets a haircut.
And I've actually missed editing.
I might be one of the few YouTubers
that actually enjoys editing.
But I tell you what, it
was quite nice not having
to worry, every single day, about (gasps),
what video am I gonna post?
Matty had a fun time at camp with Jenna.
We're goin' this way.
Come on.
Post up, post up.
There you are.
I missed this little dog so much.
("Shape of You")
Ed Sheeran is perfect,
a perfect human being.
♪ And then we start to dance ♪
♪ And now I'm singing like ♪
♪ Girl, you know I want your love ♪
♪ Your love was handmade
for somebody like me ♪
- I'm in love with your body, Matty.
Time to get his little haircut.
He's gonna look so cute.
This day is all about Matty,
whatever he wants to do.
Well, that's not true,
because if it was his choice,
he would not be getting a haircut.
That's not something that he would want.
I think he has to poo.
(back up alarm wails)
Tail is down so far, because
he knows where we're at.
He knows it's time for the haircut.
Look at that tail, down so far.
That is not how my little dog usually is.
Let's go, let's go.
There you go.
Hi, here for Matty.
Matty's still getting his hair cut,
so I thought I would just sit in my car,
because I was at a cafe, earlier,
and it was really cold out.
So I decided hey, let's go in
the car and edit some videos.
So that's what we're doin'.
It's workin' out nicely.
(motor whirs)
There we go, some extra leg room,
(computer chimes)
laptop room.
(gasps) And I'm getting Wi-Fi
from the cafe next door.
This is perfect.
Heated seats, Wi-Fi,
everything's going perfect.
(upbeat music)
All trimmed up, lookin' good.
You feeling good, bud?
(bright music)
So yesterday, Matty had
such a nice little day,
but now, I'm also having
a nice day with Ro.
I can't wait.
- Hello.
- I've seen you
so many times this week, like it's great.
- I know, this has made me really happy.
- I know, we just got back from Hawaii.
We did like a crazy kayak,
hike thing.
- Mm-hmm.
- It was so fun.
- To a waterfall,
it was beautiful, and then,
oh, we just played a few games.
- We did.
- And I made Justine do
this really weird
celebration high-five gadget.
- Yeah, this is what it was.
I'm gonna steal it from your Twitter.
- [Rosanna] Okay, cool.
And loaded, okay, Justine, high-five!
(laughs) Oh my gosh, it worked!
- That's what we just did.
- I don't know exactly where I got it.
Someone really cool sent it to me
when I went to go visit a friend.
And I was like, I gotta try this out.
- It was pretty cool.
Surprisingly, it worked,
and then Ro showed me she has this vacuum
that comes out of the wall,
which you don't have to show it again.
I'll just cut to the Snapchat.
- [Rosanna] Here's my vacuum.
I had to show you this.
It's too cool.
It's built into the wall.
It's a central vac.
Pull this red button.
And it's live.
- Let's go clean up our mess.
- Okay!
- [Man] Good to go.
- [Justine] Wow.
- [Rosanna] You could just pick it up.
- Okay, so that happened (laughs).
- It's a central vac.
I've never had one of these.
This is the first time I've
ever had one, and it's amazing.
It's changed my life.
You can just vacuum the whole house.
- Oh it's so great. and we just filmed,
well, we're gonna film another video of,
let me show you guys.
I've showed you this before.
I bought so many of these things.
They're like these
little mini-food things.
And they taste like rotten food.
(laughs) So we got this one.
It's a soda maker
and this one, chicken nuggets.
It looks so gross.
- [Rosanna] I'm a little nervous.
- I'm scared, the chicken
nuggets, especially.
- Excited 'cause I like trying new things.
Nervous because I don't
think it's meat, right.
Look, it just kind of
looks like powder paste.
- [Justine] I don't know.
- [Rosanna] That you
like mold into shapes.
- I have--
- It's more like a gummy.
- Absolutely no idea.
We're gonna find out.
And we also did a taste test
challenge on Ro's channel
of pineapple treats?
- Mm-hmm.
- So you'll see that.
- A bunch of pineapples things
when we were in Hawaii.
- It was so good.
Okay, we're gonna start filming,
and I'll see you guys later.
So I'm back home now, and I'm prepped
and ready to shoot probably
like two cooking videos.
One is actually for Saint Patrick's Day,
so it's probably not gonna be for a while.
Mmm, this kind of looks really gross.
I would've started shooting a while ago,
but I have a bunch of stuff coming
on Amazon Prime that I forgot.
I have SD cards, because I can't seem
to find two SD cards for my cameras.
I'm doing kind of a little
bit smaller of a setup,
because usually I go
all out, and it's crazy.
So I need to try to pare it down,
to make the cleanup a little bit easier.
That's something that
we're gonna be making.
So there is something that I
really, really, really want.
I never thought that I'd be
super into kitchen gadgets,
but guess what, surprise!
There's this incredible matte black mixer.
It's a KitchenAid.
So I asked Jenna if she wanted this one,
and then I would get this black one.
It looks so good.
Look, this is it.
These KitchenAid mixers are incredible.
I have abused this thing.
You guys have seen some of the things
that I have put it through.
I've also seen a ton of
people online talking
about how great they are.
Some people have had theirs
for years and years, like 28,
I think somebody said something
about they had theirs for like 18 years,
and they were hoping that it breaks,
because they wanted to get a new one,
but it basically works
like new, after 18 years.
So there's no getting a new mixer.
But man, this thing looks so good.
I just (sighs), I saw
it online, I was like,
ooh, beautiful, it would
look so good with my theme
of white and black everything.
Although, I do really like this pink,
'cause sometimes it sits in the corner,
and it's a nice pop of color.
I wish I could be shooting right now,
but I don't have SD cards.
I forgot what else I
wanted to say to you guys.
If you have any video suggestions,
feel free to leave them below.
I have been trying so hard
to prep videos in advance
so that I don't lose my mind.
Back in the day, on
YouTube, you didn't have
to make videos, every day.
Where's my Prime order?
So the video that I'm
shooting right now, this one,
I need to shoot it, edit it,
because it's going up tomorrow.
I'm making Nintendo Switch doughnuts.
I don't know how it's gonna work out.
But I'm hoping it works out really well.
I've messed things up in boxes before,
so there is a possibility
of messing this up.
I mean, nothing is ever guaranteed.
That's causing a little bit of a backup.
Oh god!
Backup.
(Justine laughs)
That's not at all what I had planned.
Scoop that over there.
This one's a little bit too full.
Scoop you in here.
Maybe it's because I'm not a baker.
I just do this for fun.
But here's the question,
am I having fun right now?
I'm not sure.
Debatable!
Wow, that's a really,
that's a really good camera angle.
Hi, good morning, good day.
I'm going to pick up Jenna,
and we're going to brunch.
It's a really busy day.
I've been sitting around my house, waiting
for the Nintendo Switch to
arrive, so I can do an unboxing.
Really, I'm not sitting
around the house, though.
I was, and then I got
super antsy and hungry,
and I got to go pick up
my dog from Jenna's house.
I wish I could take him to more shoots,
but it ends up being way more of a hassle,
trying to babysit a dog
plus actually doing my job
of whatever it is that I'm doing.
He's been on a few sets with me,
and he's been really good, actually.
But he loves to play, and he
loves hanging out with people.
The good thing is he's very quiet.
So he doesn't really make a lot of noise.
I'm gonna drive, pick up Jenna,
brunch, unbox the Switch and live my life.
(gentle music)
Jenna!
- Hello.
- Yesterday, at Ro's house,
and then before that, it was Matty's day,
and then you end up taking
Matty, because I had
to film yesterday, but
I'm gonna reclaim the dog.
- No!
We're having a great time together.
- [Justine] Has been havin' fun?
What's he been doing?
- Oh my gosh, we've been
to the dog park more times
than you can even count.
He's been pooping on everything.
He's been--
- Livin'?
- Livin', yeah, I guess.
Growling at children?
- We go on lots of walks.
We go on at least five walks a day.
- That's sweet of you.
- Long ones.
- We usually on like five short ones.
- Oh god, these are long.
My hips hurt (laughs),
all the walking.
- So this place has
homemade English muffins,
I've been told.
- I just hope it's as
good as it was, last week.
- [Justine] Look at
that muffin, rather big.
Wow, wow, wow.
- Just wait until you try it.
- [Justine] Is this a dog park activity
for Jenna or the dog (laughs)?
- Ready?
Go get it!
Come on, Matty.
- Jenna park, dog park.
Jenna park, dog park.
It's like hot and cold,
and then yes and no.
Whoa, look at that.
I'm so proud of my little boy.
He used to never play with balls.
There he is chasing and
runnin', havin' a good time.
Ooh, looks like my office
is a little bit messy.
But I'm about to set it up, clean it up
and get it ready for the Nintendo Switch.
I don't usually game up here in my office,
no, that's not true.
I game here, sitting in a chair.
Xbox, PlayStation, connects to here.
This is my PC, and then
this is an extra monitor.
But since the Nintendo Switch came out,
I like playing Nintendo
games on a bigger screen,
and I could play it
downstairs in my living room,
but if I want to capture and record,
then I have to bring my
capture stuff downstairs.
So I thought that I would
just clean up a little bit,
bring a TV that I have in
my guest bedroom into here.
I'll use that, set it
up, clean up this mess,
and this will be the gaming station.
I also got to flip this couch around.
I was hoping Jenna would
be here to help me,
but she's not here, so I
kinda have to figure out
how to do it myself.
But the question is, am I
gonna be able to carry this TV?
I think I can do it.
♪ I'm overzealous ♪
Hi, Matty.
Do you want to go upstairs
and help Mommy do some stuff?
Oh my god, this is so heavy.
This is so heavy!
(Justine shrieks)
Why, why is this, why is not
something that I'm filming?
This is so stupid.
Oh god, my, my fingers.
Ow!
Does it help if I do it this way?
No (groans).
I hate being independent.
Why can't I be a woman who likes
to have everyone else
do everything for her?
This is great.
(Justine grunts)
Here we go.
God, these socks are sexy.
(gentle music)
You guys are gettin' a real
behind-the-scenes here,
behind-the-scenes look.
Oh my god!
Ah!
Oh jeez!
Oh no!
It hurts!
How do I do it?
Ow!
Hi, Matty.
Oh thank you.
Hi.
Did you save Mommy?
You saved Mommy.
Oh (laughs), oh!
The kisses, baby.
Here, look.
Here you go.
Here you go, that's what you like.
If you're wondering why
this bucket is here,
it's because I have a leak in my ceiling.
I'm gonna get it up to the bucket.
(Justine sighs)
Great.
Okay, okay, okay, we got it.
We got it.
We got it!
And this is too, it's too (laughs),
this cabinet is too small.
(gentle music)
Hey, guys, we're at Disney, today.
I'm so excited.
Now we will commence into
the park for a fun time.
- Commence into the park?
- Commence into?
It wasn't what I wanted to
say, and then it just came out.
Let's cut to a nice, fun Disney montage.
These are--
- Let's commence to it.
- These are all gonna be fake staged shots
to make it look like we're
having an excellent time.
We are having a good time,
but it's gonna be even more fun.
Are you ready?
- I'm already having a good time.
- Jenna.
- I was here last week.
So I know everything
that I want to do again.
- This is a music montage.
Okay, ready, laugh like you're having fun.
(Jenna laughs)
- Wait, you're making a montage now,
like it's a live montage?
- [Justine] No, no, no.
- Let's montage.
- Ready, montage.
(bright music)
I'm montaging.
- [Announcer] No lap-sitting.
(bright music)
- So the real reason that
we came to Disney today was,
you know, obviously to ride rides, but--
(horn honks)
- Oh my god!
- Oh my goodness.
- I thought--
- [Child] Look at that!
- Look.
- The real reason is there is
a new tavern that opened up.
It's called Roses--
- Red Rose Tavern.
- Yeah.
- You're not even a real fan.
- How could you?
Beauty and the Beast is
coming out, this week,
so they opened up this little tavern
that's inspired by--
- Next month.
- Next month?
- Uh, March 17th.
- Oh, oh, I guess--
- [Jenna] God, you know nothing.
- Okay, well, I'm going tot
he premiere this weekend.
(Jenna laughs)
So--
- I'm a real fan.
Belle's my favorite.
- Okay, well, March 3rd,
March 2nd is the premiere,
and I will be there, and
I'm super excited about it.
So technically, it's out this week.
- Oh my god, it's the
Beauty and the Beast!
- Is that Gaston?
- No, it's the--
- Is Gaston over there?
- Actually, I think it is.
- It's Gaston!
He's here!
- What? Oh no!
- [Justine] Get in line, get in line!
- [Jenna] That I came to Disney.
- [Justine] Is Gaston making a fuss?
- Is he a teenager right now?
- Come over here!
- This Gaston is like 12.
(Justine laughs)
I don't think I want to wait.
Maybe we--
- Maybe we don't.
- Maybe we keep going.
Gaston is 13 years old.
- Gaston's 13.
- [Jenna] We got to
get a picture for Adam.
- We need to find an older one (laughs).
So Gaston was a little
too busy doing a pose off,
so I'll just try to find the next Gaston
that happens to preening
around the park (laughs).
- It said, in the description,
that Gaston may be preening,
and Maurice and Belle.
- Oh!
- If I see Belle,
I'm gonna lose my mind.
- Goodness gracious!
I feel like every time we're here,
we never actually see any characters.
- I see 'em all the time.
You must not open your eyes, woman.
- Eyes closed.
- You've got a churro
too far in your face.
(gasps) It's over there.
- [Justine] Royal Reception.
- [Jenna] Yeah, 'cause look, oh my god.
I have to get some--
- Are we here?
(Jenna gasps)
- [Jenna] I know, I'm
getting myself a gift.
- Look at all these cute little things.
- [Justine] I need you to be excited.
- [Ed] Try the gray stuff, it's delicious.
- Huh?
- Do they have the gray stuff?
- They do.
- I'm gonna get it.
- [Jenna] This is it.
- Look.
Yeah, I was expecting it to be real,
ooh, look there's little
dishes over there.
- [Jenna] Oh my god, wait.
The cups have red roses in 'em.
I'm intrigued now.
- That's cool.
Tap it.
The line is very long.
Oh, look at that.
Oh, it's hosted by Minute
Maid, #Sponsor, #Ad.
Okay, well, that was
definitely not as exciting
as I thought it was gonna be.
(dramatic music)
I don't think I'm gonna get a bucket.
I don't need that.
- [Woman] And a Coke also.
- [Clerk] Add a Coke, all right.
- [Justine] This is hidden Mickey.
Oh, I just touched it.
- (laughs) You're fine.
- [Justine] That's so cool.
- [Jenna] Are you snacking already?
- [Justine] Did you get the shot earlier?
- Yeah.
- I was losin' my mind.
So I was so excited.
I saw this bag over here coming in,
and then Ed comes over and
is like, "Look what I got."
And I was like, Ed, that is
gonna look so good on you.
And he bought it for me!
This is so great.
Oh my god, I can't wait.
It's so cute.
I can fit so many items in here.
I think my Nintendo
Switch will fit in here.
- [Ed] The Switch?
Oh, it's got little side pockets, too.
- Oh, I can put my Joy-Cons there.
Oh my gosh, I'm a Joy-Con right now.
My front bag.
We just waited about 45
minutes for Space Mountain.
- Hold on, are you leaving
the line right now?
- Yeah, 'cause they said
it was closed.
- Where do you want
to go then?
- This is gonna be
the second time that I've come to Disney
and not rode a ride.
- Me too.
Same, same experience.
- This is gonna be
the second time we've come to Disney
and not ride anything.
- Let's go wait in line for
Space Mountain and then leave.
- Let's go soar.
Let's just go and get
another latte, maybe.
- Please, I need a latte.
- [Jeff] Let's go to Pizza Port.
- I'll get pizza.
- [Justine] We are leaving.
We didn't ride a ride.
We ate.
- Second time,
no rides.
(Justine laughs)
- We didn't even get a
churra, a churro, a churro?
- [Jenna] Churro (laughs)?
- [Ed] We did less
than last time.
- Churro (laughs).
No, the last time I got a
chur, chur, churro (laughs).
- It tasted like a log.
- I can't say it.
- It was not good.
- Churro!
- Churro, Churro?
A chore?
(laughs) Churro.
I can't say it.
Wait, don't run.
Okay, Disney, bye!
Another sweet, sweet
sign of cooking videos
that have been complete.
I've got a couple in the can,
so thankfully I won't have to worry about
if there's a day that I'm like oh my God,
I don't have a YouTube
video to post for today.
I'll have a cooking video
ready to go for you.
So I'm gonna bring this vlog to an end.
So I'm gonna go play Nintendo Switch now.
I finally, finally have some free time,
now that I'm done shooting my videos,
and I'm almost all caught
up with my editing,
that I can finally start
playing Zelda, yes!
Yes, slay!
Slay, queen!
Cool, well, I'll see you later, bye.
Shoot, now I have to edit this video.
(Justine sighs)
Okay.
So I bought some extra suntan
lotion, and I told Jenna.
I was like, make sure you
don't forget the lotion.
She's like well, where is
it, and I said (laughs),
I put the lotion in the basket (laughs).
- Well, what basket?
(Justine laughing)
I feel like Breanne (laughs).
I don't understand.
- Matty?
- But what basket?
(Justine laughs)
Okay, I don't understand.
(Justine squeals)
- I put the lotion in the basket.
- [Jenna] You've got us all confused.
- No, no, no.
You're confused.
- I know!
- [Catherine] I guess
you already know that.
- [Jame] Now it places
the lotion in the basket.
(Justine laughs)
- [Catherine] Please.
Please, I want to go home.
I want to go home, please.
- It places the lotion in the basket.
(Justine laughs)
- It places the lotion.
- I want to see my mommy.
Please don't.
- Okay.
So where's the lotion in real life?
(Justine laughs)
'Cause I'm gonna leave here,
and I'm gonna forget the lotion.
I'm gonna be going home and be
like, it's not in the basket!
- Okay, but to be honest,
it's actually in a basket (laughs).
- [Jenna] You have issues.